- You know if you're
having like curry and rice
and you mix the perfect bite together,
that's what it tastes like.
(upbeat playful music)
- Today we are going to
make Hyderabadi Biryani.
It is a traditional dish.
It's made in the technique of Dum Pukht.
It's just spicy and it's full of flavors.
It's more of a festive dish in our family.
My son here is going to cook with me.
- I really, really love Biryani.
It's like probably one of
my favorite dishes ever.
- I've never made Biryani before.
- I've always had my
mom to cook it for me.
If you see all these ingredients,
it looks like most Indian
food is really complicated
and has a whole bunch of spices.
- I've cooked a bunch with my mom,
so I'm pretty confident
I can follow along.
- She is fun, but she's
kind of lazy sometimes.
I like pampering her but
now she learn herself.
- So we're gonna get started
with making the rice.
While the rice is cooking,
we are going to do
the preparation for the
gravy or the curry of it.
You got it?
So we're gonna heat the water,
we have rice here, it's
approximately a cup full of rice
and it's washed.
We are going to put the
rice into a pot of water.
- To make Chicken Biryani,
first you prepare the
chicken, marinate it.
Take three teaspoons of the vegan butter.
And we add spices to it.
We need garlic.
- This is garlic, right?
- Yes.
- (laughing)
- And give me a knife.
And then you see we grated the ginger.
Three teaspoon of garam masala.
Half teaspoon...
- There's cinnamon in Biryani?
I would not have expected.
- One teaspoon salt.
- I have worked with
the spices a little bit.
Normally my mom will mix them all
into a little container for me,
like take one spoon of this spice mix
and put it in my food.
So I don't have to really
think about it too much.
- So we take the cilantro and mint,
and we chop it into very fine pieces.
Mix it, we're making like a paste
so you can put a little
bit of water in there.
So basically what we do,
is we take the chicken
and we stab it a little bit.
So now you see, we are
marinating the chicken.
In Indian cooking, a lot
of it is love and affection
that you give to the chicken.
- You got marinade on my phone. (laughing)
- Now we are going to take some salt,
put like a quarter spoon, teaspoon.
Let's put two bay leaves in it.
- They give a nice flavor to it.
And then we put four cloves.
- How many did you put?
- I put around five of them.
Let's snap this into two
because this is pretty big.
We'll put some cinnamon in it.
- So you take the cardamom out here first
and then we crush them.
- How are you doing that so easily?
- You just open it, just
like you open a peanut.
- Now this is all
seasoned, let's close it.
Put the heat on little bit more than hot.
- Just fry them a little bit
with a little bit of mixed nuts.
When the cumin is roasting a little,
then you just put all the rice
and fry the rice a little bit.
So go ahead and saute.
- So far so good (laughing) yeah.
- So while this is gonna cook,
let's talk preparing the vegetables.
See, that's how good he is.
He knows how to do the onions.
- In this, we usually
put two medium onions.
Yeah, don't make too small.
(chopping)
- So it kinda came apart.
- (whispering) Yes!
Done!
- (laughing) he's got
more practice than I have.
- That just means I have to
do all the cutting at home.
- Did you already do
your whole onion? Oh man.
- Of course I'm waiting for
him to bring a girl home.
Look, I've taught him well. (laughing)
- So the chicken has been
marinated for an hour.
Let's take the marinated chicken
and we put it like this.
(sizzling)
- Alright so, we will put some ghee.
Ghee is purified butter, it's like love.
- Every time you say cardamom,
you wanna say lychee.
But you like stop and
then you're like cardamom.
- What is haldi in English?
- Tumeric.
- I have to like Google
what something is in English
so I can buy it at a store.
- (laughing)
Nice, nice, nice.
- Beans?
- I am putting the beans in.
Now let's put some yogurt.
- Normally, we're like cooking, she's like
"So how's like the job
applications going?"
and like where's this and where's that.
So I'm like forced to be
here and be interrogated.
- Answer my question!
- It's cooked on one side, flip it.
- Alright, so I think
our vegetables are done.
Now we are going to do Dum Pukht of it.
We have some heated milk.
So the warm milk and the saffron
is just going to release
the flavor and the color.
- Now you put like one
spoon of rice in a layer.
- We'll put some cilantro.
Let's spread the layer of rice.
- Then you put your chicken on top of it.
I'm gonna top it with rice.
So you check it, like a little bit of rice
and see if it's cooked.
- And so we're gonna
leave it for 20 minutes
and it's ready to sow.
- (applause) Yay!
- Okay, so which one is yours now?
- See, you can't tell,
that means it's good.
So this is yours.
That's really good.
- Yours looks more covered
in saffron than mine.
- So tastes like Biryani,
like good Biryani.
- (laughing) I wanna try yours.
- You had mine.
- You did a good job.
- Yeah, yours is better.
- We need a spoon for
you, okay there we go.
- That's a good one.
It was just ghee in it.
- (laughing)
- Eating Biryani, really tastes very good
when you use your hands.
- If you've never had Biryani,
you should definitely try Biryani.
Even if you can't make it
at home, well now you can.
- Maybe just have the recipe written up
and I would totally feel comfortable
cooking this on my own.
Maybe send her pictures of it,
be like, "Is this done?"
- She did awesome, and she's
usually a very good learner.
(upbeat music)